[Musique]
bonjour Harry bonjour Nicolas
on va voir le site de production c'est
ça bien sûr
alors Arly on vient de rejoindre le site
de production où est-ce qu'on est ici on
voit des j'ai l'impression que c'est des
coffres forts derrière vous on peut dire
ça mais non c'est pas tout à fait ça
c'est vraiment ici la grosse base
importante de chez l'hermann titane on
est dans l'atelier d'outillage les
outillages c'est les moules qui ensuite
sont transférés dans des presses
injection c'est ce qui permet de
fabriquer les pièces à injectées
c'est-à-dire que les moules prennent la
forme des petites pièces plastiques que
vous produisez donc ici ce qui se passe
actuellement tous les moules que vous
voyez c'est les moules qui sont en
entretien qui sortent l'atelier
d'injection qui viennent ici on les
entretient on les répare si faux on
changeait les électeurs on les nettoie
pour qu'il puisse ensuite repartir vers
l'atelier d'injection quand on en aura
besoin merci Arly Da Costa de rien merci
Nicolas je rappelle que vous êtes donc
chef d'équipe de production chez elarman
title